only five days into December and already
Nicole has run out of money to heat her
home it's cold right now and as a single
mother with no job and three young girls
she's worried about what's set to come
it's like I'm living in a freezer is
that that cold I could have the heating
on and it's still ice cold I'm worried
sick am I gonna put gas on am I able to
put gas on
do I need to try and go out and spend
money on extra clothing which is thicker
and warmer for me kids
so they can sleep at night
over the next few days temperatures are
expected to plummet as a blast of Arctic
air heads towards the UK with most of
the country at risk for the rest of the
week and even into the start of next
week those winds will bring a
significant chill and we're talking
about temperatures widely at around zero
to three celsius by day and By Night
minus three to minus six degrees in many
locations and in some spots where we've
got some Shelter From The Breeze or some
snow cover temperatures below -10
Celsius
that's why the UK Health Security Agency
issued a cold alert with health bosses
urging people to keep their homes at 18
degrees Celsius or above a priority for
our most vulnerable even if you're just
a room that you
try and keep us
with your hat and the scarf if necessary
to make sure that you feel warm and do
wrap up well if you go Outdoors
it may not look cold right now but it
certainly feels it there's no doubt
temperatures have dropped over the last
few days and with levels expected below
freezing coupled with financial
struggles it could mean an even more
brutal winter than expected
the country felt the Heat this summer it
too will feel the bitter cold leading up
to Christmas and with it comes the extra
strain on people's Health into man
Rashid Sky News Liverpool